welcome to the universe traveler you've
just spawned on an alien world
the first of bazillions of worlds you'll
be exploring during your time in no
man's sky
the only problem your ship is busted
fixing it constitutes the game's first
mission but for those eager to hit the
Stars immediately or without the
patience to figure this all out for
themselves here is what you need to do
to get your ship up and running again
okay there are three things you're going
to need to do before you ship is space
worthy first you're gonna need to repair
the launch thruster which lifts your
ship off the surface you're also going
to need to repair the pulse engine to
properly navigate space and finally you
need fuel preferably for both of these
to fix these you're going to need to
collect some stuff and craft some stuff
so we're looking for the following five
elements iron iridium zinc plutonium and
thallium 9 first of all let's get the
fuel sorted search the crash site for
supplies you should find some plutonium
and the cargo jobs littering the debris
if not these spiky rocks should do the
trick in fact you need to always be
collecting this stuff hold right trigger
to harvest and this will drop into your
exosuit inventory remember these every
time you land your ship you're going to
need plutonium to take off again
Fahmy m9 which your pulse engine needs
can be harvested via these plants if you
come across one whole square to harvest
one or two plants should suffice if you
can't find any of it don't worry though
there should be plenty of this stuff in
the asteroids surrounding your planet
next you want to grab some iron there
should be medium sized and large chunks
of it in the area surrounding your ship
you're going to use this iron to craft
car night sheets one of which should
already be in your starship inventory so
subtracting that one you're going to
need about 250 iron to craft the
five-car night sheets required each one
of them using 50 iron once you have the
requisite iron hits square on any of the
empty slots on your starship inventory
then hover over car night sheets hold X
and repeat this four more times okay
that should be a thruster fixed on one
of the requirements needed to fix the
pulse engine but we still need sink and
her idiom to get that thing fully
repaired her idiom comes in the form of
these large black obelisks which break
apart differently to the iron you need
200 of this to get going this should be
one around but if you have trouble feel
free to repair your multi-tool scanner
using 25 carbon this is a great tool to
help you locate the various elements of
Carbon can be found in living things
like plants it's also the few used to
mine to collect a bunch of that and once
your scanner is fixed hit the left
bumper to scan finally Zink isn't found
through mining rather it's harvested
from these rather unique looking plants
whole square need the plants to grab
some you only need 20 or so so a single
plant should suffice once you've
gathered all this stuff hold X on the
parts in your starship inventory to
repair them then tap X on your launch
toaster and pulse engines to load them
full of fuel and that's it you ships you
be ready to leave orbit what adventures
await you in space well that's for
another video so subscribe to GameSpot
for more tips and tricks for no man's
sky